اول شيء بلاك هات هي فعاليه هدفها الاساسي
توعيه المستخدمين وتعليمهم فلذلك كيف تقي
نفسك من الاختراق لازم تعرف كيف تخترق
الشيء عشان تقي نفسك منه فلذلك وجدت مثل
هذه الفعاليات حتى تعلم الناس اساليب
الاختراق للاجهزه وللهواتف وغيرها وبما ان
السيارات بدها تكون متطوره التقرير التي
تكون فيها شغلات تقنيه بدو يعلمونا الناس
كيف اختراق السيارات عشان يتجنبونها سابقا
اذا بغيت تسرق سياره تمام
متوقع في السيارات المتطوره التقنيه ان
يكون كل سياره لها رقم سري ولها همم ايميل
يكون موجود عندك هذا الايميل والرقم السري
عشان تستفيد الخدمات السياره لو الايميل
والرقم السري استخدمته على منصه غير
موثوقه وتم تسريب بياناتك قد يكون بامكان
الشخص فتح السياره وتشغيلها وسرقتها
موجود زي ايه اللي حصل في الارصده اللي
كانت في البنوك وراحت كثير من الفلوس
الناس لهذا السبب ربما الاختراقات بشكل او
باخر
كان يعتمدون على الهندسه الاجتماعيه كانوا
يهمونك بشيء يعني مثلا كان يطلع لك اعلان
وهمي يقول لك ايش صار من عندنا هذه الخدمه
او همم خدمات بوهميه وتحط بطاقه البنكيه
وبعدين هم يسرقون كل الفلوس اللي موجوده
عندك في البيت همم الموضوع بشكل كامل همم
الفعاليات هذه وجدت حتى تعلم الناس توعيه
التوعيه كيف يتم اختراق الشيء عشان تحمي
نفسك من الاختراق هذا فالتوعيه هي اساس
الموضوع لان التقنيه قادمه موجوده راح
تكون في كل مكان الى درجه الصناعي داخل في
حياتنا كلها وراح يتحكم في امور كثيره
يعني انا من جوالي حاليا اتحكم فيه امور
كثيره ومتعدده في اماكن مختلفه